HERE IS SOMETHING IMPORTANT,
OUR FRIEND SAID ON LAST WEEK'S
SHOW.
>> THERE IS A CRIME BILL THAT
CORY BOOKER IS BEGGING TO GET
ON BOARD.
WE TALK ABOUT INCARCERATION
GOING UP TO TWO-POINT TO
MILLION, THERE ARE AMERICAN
CITIZENS WHO ARE LOCKED UP,
FORGET OUR CONCERN THOSE
TRYING TO BREAK INTO AMERICA.
90% OF THOSE IN JAIL TOOK A
PLEA DEAL BECAUSE THEY DID NOT
HAVE ADEQUATE REPRESENTATION.
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WERE
DESTROYED.
THE BILL CLINTON CLIMBED JAN
CRIME BILL AND NOTHINGS BEEN
WRITTEN ABOUT THAT.
>> SHE'S TALKING ABOUT THE
FIRST BILL, A HISTORICAL FORM
OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM
THAT TRUMP AND HIS TEAM HAVE
WORKED HARD TO NEGOTIATE.
>> TODAY I'M THRILLED TO
ANNOUNCE MY SUPPORT FOR THIS
BIPARTISAN BILL THAT WILL MAKE
OUR COMMUNITIES SAFER AND GIVE
FORMER INMATES A SECOND CHANCE
AT LIFE AFTER THEY HAVE SERVED
THEIR TIME.
IT'S SO IMPORTANT.
>> HE'S RIGHT AND THIS IS A
MAJOR POPULACE ISSUE.
LET'S REMEMBER WHAT POSITIVE
POPULACE IS ALL ABOUT.
PRO- WORKER, PRO- COMMUNITY.
BILL CLINTON'S 1994 CRIME BILL
ENDED UP IN CARSON AIDING
MILLIONS OF WORKING AMERICANS,
FAR TOO MANY AFRICAN
AMERICANS, FOR FAR TOO LONG
HURTING THEIR ABILITY TO WORK
AND EARN A LIVING,
CONTRIBUTING TO FAMILY
BREAKDOWN IN HELPING TO TEAR
APART THE FABRIC IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
HERE IS MIKE LEE.
>> THIS BILL WOULD DEAL WITH
THAT.
THEY HAVE THE DISCRETION TO BE
JUDGES AND IT WILL MAKE LIFE
BETTER FOR MILLIONS OF
AMERICANS WHO IN ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER ARE AFFECTED BY OUR
FEDERAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM.
>> YOU GOT LINDSAY GRAHAM.
>> WHAT WERE TALKING ABOUT IS
CREATING A NEW SENTENCING
SYSTEM THAT WILL GIVE
AFRICAN-AMERICAN MALE AND
HISPANIC MALE DETAINEES A
CHANCE TO GET OUT OF JAIL.
IT'S THE MOST IMPORTANT
BIPARTISAN PIECE OF
LEGISLATION IN THE CONGRESS
TODAY.
>> YOU GOT DEMOCRATS,
INCLUDING DICK DURBIN AND CORY
BOOKER, YOU'VE EVEN GOT VAN
JONES OF ALL PEOPLE.
CHECK OUT HIS PRAISE TO
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> ON THIS ONE, I'LL GIVE HIM
AN ABSOLUTE END AND APPLAUD.
WE'VE GOT COME TOGETHER TO
HELP PEOPLE AT THE BOTTOM.
IF YOU CAN'T PUT THINGS ASIDE
TO HELP PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUFFERING IN PRISON WHEN THERE
IS A SHOT TO DO SOMETHING ON A
BIPARTISAN BASIS, THEN I THINK
WE'VE TAKEN POLITICS TO PART.
>> YOU WOULD THINK WITH ALL
THAT SUPPORT THIS BILL WOULD
EASILY PASS CONGRESS.
THAT'S WHAT THE BILL SPONSOR
CHUCK GRASSLEY IS OPENING.
HERE'S HIS TWEET, DEALMAKER
CAN GET A BIG BIPARTISAN DEAL
DONE THIS YEAR ON CRIMINAL
JUSTICE REFORM.
FIRST STEP TO ACT IS IN
DECEMBER.
WILL GOP SENATORS AND LEADER
MCCONNELL STAND-IN PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S WAY OF ACHIEVING MAJOR
BIPARTISAN VICTORY OR JOIN IN
HISTORIC AND POPULAR REFORM.
THERE'S THE PROBLEM.
THERE IS ONE HITCH IN ALL
THIS, MITCH.
MITCH MCCONNELL SEEMS TO THINK
HIS ONLY JOB IN LIFE IS
CONFIRMING JUDGES.
OF COURSE THAT IS VITAL, BUT
SO IS PRESIDENT TRUMP'S AGENDA
AND IT WOULD HELP IF THE
MAJORITY LEADER COULD ACTUALLY
HELP PASS IT.
INSTEAD HE'S BLOCKING IT.
HE WON'T BRING THE BILL FOR A
VOTE BECAUSE IT'S NOT EXACTLY
CLEAR.
>> WE DON'T HAVE A LOT OF TIME
LEFT, BUT THE FIRST STEP IS TO
FINALIZE WHAT PROPONENTS ARE
ACTUALLY FOUR.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DIFFERENT VERSIONS FLOATING
AROUND AND THEN WE WILL SEE
WHERE THE VOTE COUNT IS.
>> ANOTHER OBJECTIVE IS
OUTGOING TENNESSEE SENATOR BOB
CORKER.
A LOT OF PEOPLE LIKE ME ARE
STILL TRYING TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT IT DOES, HE SAID.
THERE HAD ONLY BEEN A HIGHER
LEVEL DISCUSSION OF WHETHER WE
SHOULD ATTEMPT TO DO IT.
I THINK THE EXPLANATION ON A
MUCH LOWER LEVEL, THE ONE
WASHINGTON USUALLY OPERATES,
MONEY.
BLOCKING THIS BILL WOULD LEAVE
MORE PEOPLE IN JAIL.
WHO WOULD BE MOST IN FAVOR OF
THAT?
THE PRISON INDUSTRY AND GUESS
WHOSE RECEIVED MORE MONEY FROM
PRIVATE PRISON COMPANIES THAN
ANY OTHER MEMBER OF THE
SENATE.
THAT'S RIGHT, GOOD OLD BOB
CORKER.
DON'T BOTHER WIPING THE MUD
OFF ON YOUR WAY OUT OF THE
SWAMP.
BOB CORKER'S OPPOSITION WHICH
HAS MR. MYSTIFIED MANY MAKES
MORE SENSE WHEN YOU REALIZE HE
HAS RECEIVED HALF A MILLION
DOLLARS FROM PRIVATE PRISON
COMPANIES OVER THE YEARS.
NEVER MIND COCAINE, THIS IS
CORRUPT.